world-renowned British Street artist
Banksy pulled off one of the greatest
pranks in the history of the art world
Banksy whose real identity is still
unknown
his famous Wars mischievious and often
satirical outdoor graffiti two seconds
after one of his most iconic works sold
for close to 1.4 million dollars at a
London auction the painting fell from
the frame and started to self-destruct
check this out Elizabeth Palmer is in
London with how the notorious prankster
pulled off this stunt Elizabeth good
morning good morning you're looking at a
Banksy on the side of a building here in
central London that one's called shop
till you drop and it's clearly a poke at
consumer culture
Banksy's made his reputation mocking the
establishment and he did it again this
weekend in spectacular fashion at
Sotheby's auction house here's the
auctioneer as bids come in for Banksy's
famous girl with balloon it sells for
over a million dollars and then as the
people in the room try to take in what's
happening the painting drops down
through a shredder in the frame and by
the time it's taken away much of it is
in ribbons Banksy himself posted this
video which includes footage of someone
presumably him installing the shredder
years ago says the video in case the
piece was ever put up for auction
Banksy's art is essentially two things
it's a graphic sort of poster propaganda
art and a performance instead of being
cut out of her painted over on a
building side it destroyed itself Banksy
who keeps his identity a secret is
famously irreverent graffiti is a crime
so nation call the police if you see
this man
he started out part of the
counterculture but his stencil street
art laced with edgy humor soon attracted
attention and rich collectors these
famous auction houses were sudden they
were selling industry are and everything
was going a bit crazy and suddenly a
will become about the money but never
about the money but in the art world it
is inevitably about money and when
you're as famous as Banksy even acts of
destruction make a profit this piece
that has been shredded is so singular
and different and newsworthy the market
is speculating that it's worth 50% more
of course the art world is abuzz this
morning with speculation that Sotheby's
had to know about this if only because
the frame would have been so heavy
however Sundby says absolutely not they
knew nothing they say they were just
bank seed John Elizabeth Palmer Utley in
London and thanks Elizabeth